[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 échos citent défiguré vol
de données encore cyberattaques nous ne
pouvons plus passer à côté de la cyber
sécurité
nous allons donc faire un point sur la
cyber défense à saint quentin en
yvelines et aussi nous rencontrerons des
entrepreneurs tourné vers l'avenir
sommaire nous irons rencontrer jonathan
bene l'un des organisateurs
d'opticsvalley d'événements organisés le
7 février dernier avait pour but
d'échanger autour de la cyber sécurité
nous ferons aussi un point sur
l'entreprise you go shine plateforme qui
permet des experts de tester les
systèmes informatiques d'entreprises
soucieuses de se protéger contre les
attaques
et puis nous avons interviewé jean
michel fourgous vice-président de 50 en
yvelines en charge du développement
économique
nous verrons avec lui avec plus de ce
que saint quentin en yvelines entreprend
en ce qui concerne la cyber défense avec
le cloud les portables ou encore les
objets connectés la cybersécurité est
devenu aujourd'hui primordial en france
selon une étude opinionway on estime que
80 % des entreprises françaises ont été
visés par une cyberattaque en 2015
les logiciels malveillants représente
61% de ses attaques
la défiguration de sites web 23% ou
encore le vol de données personnelles
18% selon l' agence nationale de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information pour
être en sécurité une entreprise devrait
consacrer 5 à 10% de son budget en cyber
sécurité
en parlant de cybersécurité en séminaire
a été organisé par opticsvalley mardi 7
février dans la salle de conférence du
crédit agricole de guerre en cours
durant toute la journée des
professionnels ont présenté des projets
innovants nous avons interviewé l'un des
organisateurs et mai
avec jonathan emmène et bonjour bonjour
alors pourquoi avoir mis en place ce
séminaire alors ce séminaire sur la
thématique de la sécurité nous importe
est alors au regard notamment de
l'actualité les actes terroristes de
l'année 2015 en particulier mais aussi
et surtout parce que la sécurité
constitue l'un des marchés applicatifs
les plus intéressants et les plus
dynamiques pour les technologies
optiques et photoniques dont
opticsvalley se charge de l'animation de
la filière
on a l'impression que c'est arrivé d'un
coup la cybersécurité qu'on en parlait
pas que c'est à un tout petit milieu
et puis là dans les médias on en parle
on en parle ça y est on y est il en faut
de la cybersécurité alors ça ça tient
notamment à l'équipement des ménages en
smartphone ça tient aux objets connectés
de manière plus générale le smartphone
en étant évidemment alors un détail ici
en fait on a abordé la question de la
cybersécurité mais on s'est quand même
attaché à se focaliser sur les
technologies de détection et l'analyse
c'est à dire de la dimension plus
hardware que véritablement software on
parle souvent de d'attac cible de cyber
sécurité pour tous les objets connectés
mais réellement ça se matérialise comme
ans qu'est ce qui pourrait arriver de
plus grave
alors on va prendre un exemple typique
c'est le fait qu'un tiers prennent
possession et le contrôle d'un objet
connecté qui vous appartient donc il
peut diffuser des photos d'ordre privé
qui sont stockées dans votre téléphone
il peut éventuellement avec des
technologies nfc effectué un paiement
sans contact que vous ne riez pas validé
de vous même enfin voilà en fait dans la
vie quotidienne
ces deux exemples assez typique d'un
hacking qui peuvent survenir et sur
lesquels aujourd'hui on a une protection
qui est quand même assez limité d'où ce
type de séminaire
je comprends mieux pourquoi et parlez
moi un petit peu du cluster alors alors
le cluster donc opticsvalley 7 1 kloster
qui existe depuis 1999
donc qui a une vraie antériorité dont le
périmètre d'action s'étend sur
l'ensemble des technologies optiques et
photoniques grosso modo on explore trois
grands volets l'interaction lumière
matière donc ça c'est tout ce qui a
trait au laser à la spectroscopie en
particulier ensuite on a la dimension
vision et optiques au sens vraiment
premier du terme avec la
vidéosurveillance avec les lentilles
optiques et à leurs propriétés et puis
en dernier lieu on à la transformation
de la lumière sous la forme d'énergie
avec le photovoltaïque ou sous la forme
d'un signal avec de la fibre optique
donc on a vraiment tout ce périmètre
voilà d'actions ce qui nous permet en
fait d'avoir un plan d'action qui est
relativement dense et là encore assez
vaste retour de la pratique des objets
connectés et donc on ne s'interdit pas
d'explorer des marchés applicatifs comme
la sécurité aujourd'hui comme la
réalité augmentée demain à savoir demain
c'est une manière de dire voilà non
c'est dans deux mois là et puis enfin
voilà on essaie de faire des petites
commentaires des petites exploitations
spots sur une thématique à plusieurs
reprises pendant l'année de manière à
accorder une tribune à nos adhérents et
également pour leur donner donc une
visibilité et finalement intervenir
comme comment dire on va essayer
finalement d'assurer une certaine forme
de veille technologique et marché pour
tous les acteurs de l'écosystème qui à
l'occasion de ces séminaires se déplace
chez nous et bien merci messieurs venez
merci beaucoup à vous désirez faisons un
point sur l'entreprise
yugo chars cette entreprise de
cybersécurité fait du bug bounty une
sorte d'anti virus qui révolutionne la
cybersécurité focus sur l'entreprise
yogo chat qui dirigent des white accord
ue gauche a est pionnière dans
l'utilisation du bug bounty en europe
une méthode qui a vu le jour aux états
unis et que la société a emporté en
france aujourd'hui c'est l'une des
manières les plus fiables en termes de
cybersécurité on s'adresse non pas une
entreprise qui emploie à des hackers on
s'adresse à une communauté de hackers à
travers une plateforme est plutôt que de
leur dire qu'on va payer le temps qui
vous passez à chercher on va le racheter
leurs découvertes cercle des hackers
vont chercher des failles et quand ils
en trouvent ils des rapporte et
l'entreprise qui est client de la
plateforme va acheter les failles plus
elles sont critiques plus elles sont
chères sûrement tarifs qui établit à
l'avance yosha gère environ 70 acteurs
chercheurs pour avoir un travail de
qualité
l'entreprise met les bouchées doubles
pour créer un lien de confiance avec
l'équipe son lit de développeurs
travaillent plus de 12 heures par jour
quand on a un une erreur sur un site il
faut qu'un développeur la corrige mais
pour qu'ils puissent avoir connaissance
qui doit la corriger ont créé ce qu'on
appelle un ticket et dont ce ticket on
va décrire l'erreur et comment la
résoudre donc je vais faire ça ensuite
je vais traiter certaines vulnérabilités
je vais payer des hackers aussi durant
la journée parce qu'on paye les hackers
pour les failles qui nous remonte
je peux être amené aussi à faire des
réunions avec les autres développeurs de
façon à voir sur quoi ils travaillent
comment les orienter
est ce qu'il ya des points bloquants
pourquoi on dérive sur telle ou telle
fonctionnalité ce genre de choses les
hackers chercheurs sont payés entre 50
et 1000 euros selon la faille
aujourd'hui au gauche a été saluée pour
son travail lors du grand prix de
l'innovation de la ville de paris il
prépare aujourd'hui une levée de fonds
pour agrandir leur équipe
vous avez pu le voir dans ce reportage
la cybersécurité devenu primordial pour
les entreprises et surtout pour
affronter le monde de demain
faisons un point avec jean michel
fourgous vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines en charge du développement
économique
bonjour monsieur frog's bonjour alors
vous êtes ici opticsvalley ce un
séminaire pour moi c'est important pour
une agglomération de saint quentin
d'être ici parce que saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
donc dans le développement économique on
mais l'accélération sur certains
secteurs à forte croissance
vous savez si vous les financer tout le
système faut d'abord faire monter ce qui
monte vite qu'ils vont payer le système
pour les autres bons donc on met un coup
d'accélérateur sur ce secteur sécurité
défense qui est d'un marché quasiment à
deux chiffres bon en termes de
croissance qui est assez rare
deuxièmement la ville du futur sur
laquelle on travaille à saint quentin et
bien englobe bien sûr la sécurité du
futur
donc on a près d'une quarantaine de
petites entreprises start up ou pme qui
travaillent donc sur ces évolutions
techniques et en plus vous avez les
quatre mastodontes cas gros que sont
thales thales dassault puisque c'est une
maison aujourd'hui vous avez airbus
sécurité défense et safran donc voyez où
on est c'est bien sûr que tous ces
petits et ses moyens bénéficie aussi des
gros donc faire travailler les gros les
petits c'est bien sûr notre objectif à
saint quentin sur un marché à forte
croissance donc et qui correspond aussi
aux besoins de la ville de la ville du
futur qui bien entendu aujourd'hui à
exiger des normes de sécurité supérieur
à ce qu'on a pu connaître dans le passé
oui il faut avertir aussi le public par
rapport à la cybersécurité comment se se
protéger on parle beaucoup des
entreprises mais le public avec les
objets connectés aussi qui arrivent
oui demain vous aurez parle de jeu pas
80 milliards d'objets connectés qui vont
d'ici 2020 bien sûr c'est une vraie
révolution lumière qui n'en est qu'à son
balbutiement comme on dit donc demain
vous allez vraiment vivre dans un autre
monde où se régler comme on dit on a
acquis
la connaissance nous autres êtres
humains terriens entre guillemets en
3000 ans et en fait aujourd'hui on est
qu'on pense que dans les dix ans vous
allez doublé
ce que vous avez acquis en 3000 ans dont
vous imaginez 3000 en dix ans donc le
numérique et en même temps se remet
complètement les comportements mais en
même temps d'information vis-à-vis du
public que vous le disiez il ya aussi le
fait que même les universités ni lui à
saint quentin à un cycle de formation
spécialement sur sur sur la sécurité sur
donc tout ce qui est bien sûr le
numérique d'envoyer au soutien public
privé laboratoires privés publics
universités on se met à cette nouvelle
page et c'est bien d'ailleurs cessé
c'est bien que la france soit présent ce
cas un pays cas car niveau que ces
difficultés mais casse un niveau de
technicité dans le monde et dans
l'exportation de voix aussi
donc voilà il faut garder cette place et
saint quentin il a aussi pour soutenir
cette r&d et donc favorisées et des no
no no dont jeunes chercheurs y en a déjà
présents ici aujourd'hui et nos
laboratoires qui sont aussi très
présents le besoin de voilà c'est un
cetain s'éteint c'est vraiment un marché
qui correspond aux objectifs
prioritaires bien sûr de développement
aussi de de 50 ans au delà de
l'automobile au delà l'énergie au delà
du secteur bancaire au delà du numérique
le secteur c'est que la défense est un
axe très prioritaire à saint quentin
eh bien merci monsieur fraude merci
place à l'agenda
[Musique]
et une date à noter 21e semaine de
l'emploi et de la formation ça se
déroule du 23 février au 3 mars
tous les acteurs de l'emploi et de la
formation du territoire propose des
services et des nouveautés pour booster
l'emploi pour connaître le programme
rendez vous sur le site www.skype.com
faire c'est une éco c'est fini on se
retrouve dans 15 jours et surtout bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]